bonjour frédéric a lancé l merci de
répondre aux questions sur rt france
benyamin nétanyahou qui félicite joe
biden c'est une tentative de
rapprochement israël perd un allié de
poids non avec donald trump et se
rejoindraient conseiller jared kushner
très proche de l'état hébreu alors deux
questions l'une dehors pour féliciter
nécessairement le président et lui même
s'il ne vous plaît pas ça c'est une
certitude absolue
et c'est vrai notamment entre deux
alliés puisque les états unis et israël
ça vous a pas échappé depuis au moins
les années 60 sont très proches voire
aujourd'hui parfaitement taillé pour ça
c'était une passage obligé pour
netanyahou par ailleurs c'est pas
totalement un exercice de style
effectivement bailon connais bien les
affaires internationales et le proche
orient en particulier a toujours regardé
ailleurs de deux histoires présence de
sa famille politique à la droite du
parti le parti démocrate
et ça c'est vrai depuis les années 70 en
revanche vous avez raison de dire que
subodorer que netanyahou aurait préféré
trump parce que le fomc a été
effectivement à peu près inconditionnels
la politique de netanyahu
mais attention je veux pas dire que
revenir en fait il ne reviendra pas la
modification la localisation dans
versailles il me reviendra évidemment
pas sur la reconnaissance de l'annexion
du du plateau du golan et de jérusalem
il peut le faire et encore et encore si
le sénat le laisse faire parce que pas
du tout sûr que vous savez que le sénat
bascule le démocrate c'est de relancer
les négociations avec de tenter de faire
remettre en quelque sorte sur les rails
un processus de négociation israélo
palestinien on sa trogne s'en fichait
complètement vend donc s'arranger
évidemment netanyahu et jean montré bon
ça a été très bien dis par votre
collègue le trump s'est retiré avec
fracas du de l'accord nucléaire iranien
si plus puis j'ai demandé à l'époque pas
israël il est vrai sans l'accord et le
souhaitent y revenir enfin dernier point
mais c'est vraiment de la quasi
cosmétiques les la liste va
vraisemblablement eu effectivement on
relance et l'aide sociale et économique
à l'autorité palestinienne
enfin là on n'est pas sûr lourd on est
en réalité sur des budgets qui sont ils
par peu assez mince et d'autres encore
qui permettrait justement à l'autorité
palestienne ne pas s'effondrer
huriez on est on est pas sur une
tendance lourde qui reviendrait sur ce
qui a été fait par mes couettes
justement des démons et seront avec les
territoires palestiniens on sait que les
palestiniens ont gagné en espoirs avec
avec le démocrate il ya un mahmoud abbas
un qui a parlé hier
et puis la colistière de joe biden
kamala harris part d'ouvrir une
permanence diplomatique palestinienne à
washington
ou plus exactement de la couvrir parce
qu'on aurait évité de reagan égard dans
sa dernière la fin de son bail mandat
qui avait reconnu en fait le ep
l'organisation libération de palestine
nous étions en 89 et depuis 89 90 les
etats-unis non je n'en ont toujours
reconnu löw était alors certainement pas
le ramasse d'ailleurs reconnu d'ailleurs
pas pratiquement personne dans les oeufs
dans le giron international émis en
revanche l'autorité palestinienne légal
et légitime de mahmoud abbas a fortiori
depuis les accords d'oslo 93 à écouter
c'est une entité politique qui a
toujours été non seulement reconnu par
les états unis mais qui étaient
encouragés à la négociation
souvenez-vous des accords d'oslo au
alors j'allais dire au même titre pas au
même titre que la ville serait bien
parce qu'il sera l'allié des etats-unis
met enfin en tout cas j'ai une certaine
équanimité donc on va n'ont pas vu venir
mais revenir à ce qui existait
auparavant
ce qui d'ailleurs en soi est une très
bonne chose j'ajoute un point si vous
permettez vous avez dit avec raison le
que trump étaient de très proches ou où
les leviers de l'agneau mais n'étaient
ni dans un an
en vertu de l'accord de deux rotations
gouvernementale vous parlez d
des conséquences plus globale au
moyen-orient tout à l'heure avec
notamment l'iran le fameux jc p o et
l'accord de vienne de 2015 justement par
rapport à la politique de joe biden s'il
est confirmé par les grands électeurs à
me re américain au moyen-orient avec
cette stratégie du conflit israélo
palestinien si ça change
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
parce qu'il ya l'iran effectivement mais
à l'arabie saoudite via l'irak et le
liban
quelles répercussions j'ai envie de dire
dans cette région alors je pense d'abord
que l'arabie séoudite c'est une
véritable constante dans la politique
américaine et c'est vrai depuis là comme
quincy
il attend même 2 février 1945 est le
fondateur du royaume uni où est cette
cette relation s'est même renforcé ces
dernières années en dépit de certains
visby puisque salalah d'accords de
défense américain vis-à-vis de l'arabie
saoudite a été prorogé sine et ils ont
donc là on est sur une tendance
extrêmement lourdes même si trump en a
fait le béa à sa politique étrangère
indépendamment de les questions liées à
la chine je ne vois vraiment pas
pourquoi et comment bailon renoncerait à
sa or si vous suivez la politique
saoudienne
vous suivez bien évidemment l'accord qui
d'ailleurs là aussi ça a été très bien
rappelé a été saluée par baï donne à
l'accord de reconnaissance d'israël par
les émirats et par bahreïn
en revanche je pense qu'il y aura
vraisemblablement un apaisement avec
l'iran pourquoi parce que barack obama
avait effectivement réussi à à faire
conclure et affaires conclues en
décèdent accord qui ne concerne pas que
les états unis et l'iran mais qui
concerne huit grandes puissances toute
la france la grande bretagne l'allemagne
la russie et la chine est depuis 2010
huit trains pendant s'était retirée
c'est d'accord mais avec d'exercer des
pressions herculéenne contre ses alliés
européens pour que ceux ci ne fasse pas
entre guillemets de business avec l'iran
conformément à ce qui était prévu dans
cet accord
je pense que là bas il donne va tenter
dans un cadre à la fois multilatérale
abaissement de revenir à cet accord qui
je le précise n'est pas seulement frappé
au coin de l'humanisme ça vous aurez
sans doute surpris mais frappé au coin
de
nuit parce que l'iran est dans un état
l'économie iranienne est dans un état
catastrophique et les entreprises
américaines comme les entreprises
européennes russes et chinoises
souhaitent pouvoir le pénétrer ce marché
potentiellement très lucratif en échange
bien sûr de renoncement à téhéran a
disposé de la bande donc si vous voulez
de ce point de vue là et là je vous
rejoindrai de ce point de vue là je
rentre bailon interio il peut y avoir
pour le coup des difficultés mais pour
moi c'est à peu près le seul à mener la
seule question importante
moyenne-orientale sur laquelle il
pourrait y avoir un vrai gadret fossé
entre eux netanyahu dont je rappelle que
dans un an principe n'est plus au
pouvoir en israël et et giovan merci à
frédéric encel pour ce décryptage
complet je rappelle que vous êtes maître
de conférences à sciences po paris et
auteur notamment un des 100 mots de la
guerre aux éditions puf